[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en 324 este es un
magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre de liliana
valencia de aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad los hechos de actualidad de
la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
un apretón de manos en costa de márfil
abrió el camino de la reconciliación el
actual presidente a las agua tara se
reunió con su rival histórico el ex
presidente lord embargo tras su regreso
al país la disputa entre ambos dio
origen a la guerra civil de 2011
argelia y egipto le manifestaron su
apoyo incondicional al presidente de
túnez caixa y el que recientemente
decidió congelar el parlamento y
destituir al primer ministro la nación
enfrenta a esta nueva crisis política al
tiempo que reciente los estragos de la
pandemia de kobin 19 los atletas
africanos han arrasado con las pruebas
de fondo en los juegos olímpicos de
tokio el medallero continental crece
este año también gracias al surf al tec
hondo y a la natación
tenemos análisis en este capítulo de
áfrica siete días
y seamos entonces hablando de cosa
mártir porque el actual presidente a las
aguas para tener unido con el
expresidente laurent gbagbo el encuentro
marca el inicio de un camino de
reconciliación después de que la disputa
electoral entre ambos fuera el origen de
la guerra civil que dejó más de 3.000
muertos entre los años 2010 y 2011 va
por regreso a la escena nacional en
julio pasado después de ser absuelto por
la corte penal internacional de la haya
donde estuvo detenido por casi una
década
un encuentro que hace diez años parecía
imposible
los antiguos rivales buscan la
reconciliación en un apretón de manos
histórico para costa de marfil el 27 de
julio alassan ouattara recibió a su
antiguo rival y ex presidente lo
compacto los eventos pasados fueron
dolorosos hubo muchas muertes de humor
absolutoria no debemos poner eso atrás a
trabajar en el futuro en la cuestión y
en la reconciliación la reunión de
guacara y back boom que se había
anunciado con antelación representa la
posibilidad de aliviar tensiones
políticas que dieron origen a la guerra
civil de 2002 que dejó al menos 3000
muertos y un millón de desplazados
backbone espera que este es el primero
pero no el último encuentro espero que
podamos mantener estas reuniones cada
cierto tiempo en las que podamos aclarar
temas para el país
tras ocho años esperando un juicio los
un backbone regresó a costa de márfil el
17 de junio
después de ser absuelto por la corte
penal internacional en la haya de varios
cargos de crímenes de guerra después de
unas reñidas elecciones en diciembre de
2010 la tara fue declarado presidente
resultados que el entonces mandatario
los combativos rechazó así iniciaron
alrededor de cuatro meses de
enfrentamientos entre partidarios de
ambos candidatos
gbagbo fue capturado en 2011 por
milicias pro ouattara apoyadas por
tropas francesas presentes en el país
diez años después está de nuevo en la
nación que intenta poner fin al doloroso
capítulo de la guerra civil continuamos
con política porque egipto y argelia
expresaron su total apoyo al presidente
de túnez caixa jet quien recientemente
decidió remover de su cargo al primer
ministro y congelar el parlamento en
respuesta a manifestaciones
antigubernamentales en varias ciudades
del país el presidente egipcio abdel
fatal si si acuerdo con el ministro
relaciones exteriores de argelia ramdam
slam habrá apoyar al mandatario tunecino
en medio de la nueva crisis política que
vive el país esto mientras también la
nación enfrenta un difícil momento en
cuanto a la pandemia de ccoo y 19 los
principales reclamos de la ciudadanía
tiene que ver con la gestión que el
gobierno le ha dado a la crisis
sanitaria veamos
569 mil contagios y 18.000 decesos en un
país de casi 12 millones de personas
hacen de túnez el segundo país más
afectado por el cob y 19 en áfrica
los doctores están perdiendo las
esperanzas en el sistema de salud
tunecino pero estamos acá por nuestros
pacientes y tratamos de hacer lo mejor
que podemos en el primer caso de
coronavirus se registró el 4 de marzo de
2020 desde entonces los contagios han
aumentado sin control colapsando
hospitales y morgues
a veces tenemos entre 13 y 14 cuerpos al
día pero sólo podemos realizar 9
entierros diarios que es lo máximo que
permiten los protocolos
la crisis sanitaria ha cobrado el cargo
de ministro de sanidad a 6 personas el
más reciente howse y mehdi fue
destituido la semana pasada la llegada
de la variante delta que desde finales
de junio causa entre 150 a 200 muertes
diarias hace que la cuarta ola del virus
sea la peor hasta el momento según our
world in their a 825 mil personas han
sido inmunizadas por completo en el país
sin embargo el presidente de túnez caixa
it
aseguró hace unos días que en las
próximas semanas un total de 5 millones
de tunecinos serán inmunizados en la
actualidad en el país rige el toque de
queda hasta el 31 de julio entre las 8
de la noche y las 5 de la mañana están
prohibidos los eventos sociales
deportivos y religiosos aunque los
ciudadanos no lo respetan mucho ante la
crisis españa francia italia china y
arabia saudita donaron vacunas sin
material médico
continuamos con el coi 19 porque durante
el último mes el continente ha
registrado un aumento de los casos del
80 por ciento la organización mundial de
la salud advierte que las campañas de
vacunación de los países africanos
avanzan demasiado lento y hace un
llamado a los países con más vacunas
compradas aumentar su colaboración con
el continente africano
las salas de urgencias están al límite
del colapso en dakar algunos pacientes
no pueden ser atendidos y las reservas
de oxígeno están al mínimo en varios
hospitales
el personal sanitario califica la
situación de catastrófica
las plagas con oxígeno de momento están
todas ocupadas y la mayoría de los
pacientes en las unidades de cuidados
intensivos no están vacunados pero tras
un arranque difícil
la campaña de vacunación va de a poco
tomando ritmo al principio no quería a
vacunarme porque había rumores de que
los fármacos no eran seguros y tenía
miedo pero después pensé que en la
situación actual era mucho mejor
vacunarse el aumento del 80% de los
contagios en áfrica en el último mes es
debido en parte a la variante del está
altamente transmisible según advirtió la
o ms que instó de nuevo a los países
ricos a promover una repartición más
igualitaria de las vacunas frente a la
desigualdad actual en las campañas de
inmunización realmente aceptan un 15 por
ciento en áfrica mientras que en algunos
países es del 70% no necesitaríamos una
plata
forma como la de los olímpico para
explicar la verdad que el mundo lo está
siendo moralmente epidemiológicamente y
económicamente mal el miércoles
finalmente arrancó la vacunación en uno
de los últimos países del mundo donde
todavía no había empezado la
inmunización déjenme asegurarles
compañeros tan sanos que el gobierno
garantizará que hayan suficientes
vacunas en el país para todos los que
quieran recibirlas sin estar obligados a
ello en américa a pesar del aumento de
los casos las autoridades de ruanda
levantaron el confinamiento de la
capital kigali y de otros ocho distritos
en uganda también van desapareciendo las
restricciones debido al descenso de
muertes y hospitalizaciones en los
últimos días
en etiopía más de 100.000 niños de la
región del tigre podría sufrir
desnutrición aguda en los próximos 12
meses así lo advirtió la unicef hace
nueve meses la región se encuentra en
medio de un fuerte conflicto que ha
derivado en una hambruna la onu pide que
se permita inmediatamente la entrada de
ayuda humanitaria
la malnutrición infantil en la región de
tigre está cerca de ser una tragedia
alimentaria así lo comunicó el fondo de
las naciones unidas para la infancia
unicef y un estado asterix unicef
calcula que más de 100 mil niños en
tigres podrían sufrir desnutrición aguda
grave que pone en peligro su vida en los
próximos 12 meses un aumento de 10 veces
en comparación con el número de casos
anual promedio
la zona vive una intensa hambruna
provocada por el conflicto entre el
frente de liberación popular de tigre y
el ejército de etiopía además de sus
aliados eritreos y las fuerzas
regionales de amar a la ayuda
humanitaria el territorio es fuertemente
restringida el 18 de julio una caravana
del programa mundial de alimentos fue
atacada y actualmente se impide el
acceso de comida la onu exhortó al
gobierno etíope a permitir el ingreso
inmediato de la asistencia alimentaria
del server y una cosa que es un pedido
muy concreto que nosotros el presidente
etíope es que el gobierno debe permitir
que los trabajadores humanitarios lleven
equipos de comunicaciones adicionales
y también que proporcione visas con
mayor plazo provide long asambleístas
house staff el conflicto que explotó en
noviembre el año pasado en la agitada
región ha dejado miles de muertos y más
de 2 millones de personas desplazadas
según la onu 5.2 millones de personas
sólo en tigre necesitan asistencia
humanitaria es decir un 90 por ciento de
la población
vamos con noticias deportivas porque los
atletas africanos se imponen en las
competencias de atletismo de fondo en
los juegos olímpicos de tokio también
registran destacadas participaciones
entre kondo natación y surf los detalles
con nuestra experta en deportes el mar
está el país africano mejor ubicado del
medallero es sudáfrica en el puesto 32
con una medalla de oro lograda por
tatiana acción médica en los 200 metros
pecho de la natación y 2 de plata 1 de
la propia schoemaker en los 100 pecho y
otra de bianca violenta que en el sur un
deporte que debuta en el programa
olímpico este año otro país africano es
túnez sorprendió gracias a dos juveniles
en la natación con el oro de
no huí en los 400 metros libros y en el
taekwondo gracias a mohamed jalil
yendubi que había brillado en los juegos
olímpicos de la juventud y ganó un
bronce en los 58 kilogramos acá en tokio
en el puesto 39 aparece etiopía gracias
al logro de ese lemon bar ega en los
10.000 metros del atletismo la plata del
hambre la mesa irma en los 3.000 metros
con obstáculos y el bronce de budapest
se da en los 5000 marruecos produjo la
gran sorpresa del atletismo al acabar
con la larga seguidilla de nueve oros de
kenia en los 3.000 metros con obstáculos
lo hizo gracias al triunfo de subían el
fullback al y kenia se conformó con una
medalla de bronce en esa prueba a través
de benjamin king en y acumula también
una plata gracias a helen o billy en
5000 metros pero sigue en deuda con la
gran expectativa en torno a su habitual
dominio en las pruebas de fondo el otro
que figura en el medallero es uganda con
el poseedor del récord mundial de 10.000
metros
josep de gei con plata en esa prueba y
jake op kiplimo con broun
egipto tiene también dos bronces ambos
entre cuando con 66 en los 80 kilogramos
masculinos y malak en los 67 femeninos
en esa categoría en matlab comparte
bronce con la atleta de costa de marfil
ruth ex baby y finalizamos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días con música que nos
llega desde colombia donde el rapero y
productor alexis play le canta a áfrica
en compañía la agrupación espiral 7 la
canción rinde homenaje a la herencia
africana en colombia y a la historia que
no cuentan los libros oficiales de
historia de esa nación maleta llena de
contenido y una producción musical de
alta calidad en de áfrica un nuevo éxito
en materia de identidad así finalizamos
este capítulo de áfrica siete días
ustedes continúen con más de 324
puntocom nos vemos más adelante
[Música]
cicatriz
no
[Música]
mira
por nuestra gente este remanente
fue todo